breaking news subpoenas flying in the
battle over impeachment House Democrats
now demanding president Trump's personal
attorney rudy giuliani hand over
documents about ukraine this is the
latest move from Democrats as they move
full speed ahead teeing up a potential
impeachment vote by the end of the year
meantime President Trump hammering the
whistle blower and says the White House
is trying to figure out who it is well
we're trying to find out about a
whistleblower the call was perfect when
the whistleblower reported it he made it
sound terrible and then you had Adam
Schiff who even worse made up my words
the reason is when he saw my call to the
president of Ukraine it was so good that
he couldn't quote from him because there
was nothing done wrong it was perfect
Democrats say a potential hearing with
the whistleblower could happen very soon
both sides showing they're digging in
for a fight it's all hearsay you can't
get a parking ticket conviction based on
hearsay we could not ignore what the
President did he gave us no choice this
is not about getting Joe Biden in
trouble this is about Easter moving that
Donald Trump was framed by the dent
believes that it is is god-given right
to shakedown foreign leaders for help in
his re-election the president did
nothing in this phone call that's
impeachable and Rudy Giuliani was just
subpoenaed by the Democrats about this
issue and so we'll see how that turns
out and he might talk about it tonight
he will be on Hannity 9:00 p.m. Eastern
so you can catch Rudy's latest there let
me first go to you Jesse this hearing
that there was a blower will have it
would be behind closed doors so even
though people are anxious to figure out
who it might be
the protections that are afforded under
the law continue yes Congress never
leaked so we're not gonna hear anything
about that testimony for sure I mean if
the whistleblower didn't hear the call
who told him about the stuff that
happened on the call well and why didn't
they blow the whistle why they several
people several people told this one guy
why they all tell one guy it just seems
like a setup to me the other thing is
where was Biden this weekend while I was
Biden
doing every Sunday show pulling the full
Ginsberg you'd think that now in the
moment of the campaign he'd be out there
defending his honor
rebutting all of these false allegations
according to his campaign but instead he
had the media do all the defense of him
I guess you know when you're Democrat do
you know what the Biden people are
thinking because they have decided you
know basically to downplay it he's been
doing his campaign stuff but not talking
about
I would agree with the the vice
president staff look he's running for
president United States he is out there
talking to voters raising money trying
to meet the deadline this this decision
by the house to launch an impeachment
inquiry is is one of their solemn duties
and responsibilities the framers gave
this responsibility to the House of
Representatives I hope it's conducted in
a fair manner so that we don't spend the
next however alone trashing people
demonizing people when it is their
solemn duty and responsibility to
conduct this in a fair and accurate way
when they pull evidence like for the
Ukrainian when I don't know all the
details but when the House Democrats
subpoena somebody like Rudy Giuliani who
is the president's personal lawyer he
doesn't work for the government but he
has been talking about how he has text
messages on his phone that say the State
Department knows so do you know what the
law would be does the president have
personal attorney-client privilege in
this case or is it different
right well the attorney-client privilege
only extends between the President and
Rudy Giuliani Giuliani and part of what
he was saying on TV and on multiple
outlets is the fact that these this
production of documents is from like
multiple sources State Department
representatives etc so it's those
documents that Congress is subpoenaing
not conversations between he and the
president and in terms of the executive
privilege that doesn't apply because he
wasn't working at the past of him right
because the whole point is to determine
whether or not he was a vehicle acting
on the president's personal behalf using
an instrument of the state we were about
day ten into this story Greg how you
holding in there not well I have to say
I'm sick of this story I'm absolutely
sick of this story and it's only begun
and I realize so why am i sick of it
because I've heard it before
this is this impeachment has been served
18 different ways right since 2016
I can't stomach it it's like they keep
remix incurring that it will be a hit
but I can tell it's not going to happen
and I'm gonna put on my therapist hat
here you don't have to like the guy to
know this is BS it's been going on for
three years I hated the Dodgers but I
knew they were a good team you don't if
you want to get rid of this guy because
of his personality just realize that
this is gonna come back and haunt you
because you're gonna have half of
America that's gonna go after your guy
or girl when this happens and then
trying to get Biden off TV which was
what the what I mean not Biden Biden's
team trying to get Giuliani off
television I'm a strange thing it is a
strange thing especially when you are
allowed to have Adam Schiff on TV but
also because he's a member they honest
yeah but he's still he's still a liar I
mean tried to get Trump tried to
get making pictures of Trump so he
actually did what he's accusing Trump of
doing that leave that or not believe it
or not we actually have a call for oh
very call you're talking about I had no
idea what we have seen in that call
record is a President of the United
States used the full weight of his
office to manufacture dirt on his
opponent so you have recordings of both
so check and boost OVA where they're
discussing the compromising material on
mr. Trump absolutely well obviously we
would welcome a chance to get copies of
those recordings during a prank call
don't ever and he didn't know it was a
prank call he thought it was legit so
Democrats can ask foreigners to
investigate Trump but Trump can't ask
foreigners to investigate Democrats got
it everybody that's what this is all
about and there's a lot of fake news
coming out of the Biden campaign because
they keep on saying that you know what
everybody in Europe wanted this one
prosecutor fired and I thought to myself
moon I wonder why that is
and I went to start looking and who was
on the board of directors of burries m'a
and guess what I found
Alan Apter from Renaissance Capital the
Russian investigate investment bank that
paid Bill Clinton a half a million
dollars to speak in Moscow he's the
director then we have code for black CIA
we have the former President of Poland
and we also have Devon Archer who's John
Kerry's former
foreign policy advisor very
well-connected very wealthy group of
individuals and they wanted to get the
word out to their friends that this guy
was a corrupt investigator and he needed
to be fired but you know what we found
some documents that prove that was a
disinformation campaign Purisima hired i
believe it was a blue star strategies
ADC consulting firm to put out the fake
news about the prosecutor that everybody
bought and then the guy gets fired and
the Blue Star Strategy Group came back
to Ukraine and apologized for putting
out all this fake information about
their prosecutor and the Ukrainian
prosecutor who was fired testified under
oath that he was fired because he
wouldn't drop this investigation into
the firm that Joe Biden's son was a
member of and Joe Biden's son were never
investigated the Abidin appointed
prosecutor who came in after the other
guy was fired never opened up an
investigation into Joe Biden or his son
so he never investigated him and he
never cleared him and I wanted to put
that out there because there is a lot of
fake news out there about this story
I just want to complete a thought that I
why did Nancy Pelosi Pelosi said why
this phone call was important it was
because it was a simpler clearer way to
impeach Trump so that the public would
understand it right this was an easier
way for them to understand it so this
has all been like a Cinderella slipper
you know they've been searching for that
one shoe that's gonna fit and they went
through a warehouse of shoes before they
got to this one but if they don't get
this one they'll just find another so we
know what this is last word here you
know there's so much that I could debunk
but we don't have we have just an hour
one of the things that I've enjoyed
reading about all of this and the change
in narrative that I hear not just from
the White House and the allies of the
White House but also the change in
information that we're getting out of
Ukraine this is why we need an inquiry
so I so that we can learn the facts
expose the truth and the more we get
into this hyperbole and trying to defend
our sides and not looking at the truth
the farther way we are going to get from
resolving this matter final quick final
point on strategy I'm just respond what
you're saying about the glass slipper
the hardest cases to prove in the court
of public perception are the ones where
you keep amending the complaint or you
keep amending the charging documents and
the fact that this has been a slow leak
of festering wound for years without
this proverbial smoking gun means that
the court is or that the public is
totally fatigued we're exhausted there's
nothing there's no aha it's not a tight
case about this would be a matter of
consideration and they knew that it
would take time for us to discuss this
that's the framers were smart and
donateed were they indeed